port Han is studying to be a dentist and
you guys know that I love to talk about
also you know some of the natural means
of healing the body the good real food
and there's something in his mom that's
real powerful that many people have
forgotten about is the Miss wall
now you will the paper on this one yes I
actually wrote a research on the miswak
and how from then dental perspective how
it affects dental health and studies
have found that it has multiple but
multiple benefits for the organism
actually its most of the authors say
even non-muslims a lot of the majority
of the non-muslim say that it is a far
more superb than any toothbrush that is
today used an even from some painted
faces that they're being used so but
you've done you do to how much time did
you spend in to research English you're
looking at yes give us a day to spend
like two months on it yeah two months
yeah two months and that that pop that's
paper is not now published it that's one
of the medical journals but it's
actually an embossing language but I
have I wrote it initially in English but
it was translated to be as for the
Boston Public
now what motivated you to do that you
know we got the two project at the to
miss one because I know the hadith of
the process awesome
who said that if he didn't want it to
make it hard for his own ma he would
ordered to use the miswak before every
salat and that encouraged me because I
really believe that the Islam is the
true religion and the Prophet is is the
messenger Allah I went with a of some
assumption that's whatever he said is
completely true and that was that was my
goal so I just researched that matter
and it turned out to be exactly true so
and I have
maybe if I can say an advice for
everybody who is into science and who
likes to take on to science whoever
believes in that this LOM is the true
religion and the Quran in the hadith are
from God they're already ahead one step
ahead now why because scientists usually
take some hypothesis and they spend
fifteen to twenty thirty years to find
out that hypothesis wasn't true they
spend so much time to find that that
wasn't true in Islam all you have you
already have I have a virus hypothesis
that is true all you have to do is just
pull it yeah that's deep
so what do you recommend for people who
are tuning in they don't know much about
Islam they find us talking about the
mists walk but what's the most important
thing that you know okay this is
something out health benefits for the
teeth but something more important that
people like because I heard you do some
a lot of Dawa out here yes yeah and what
do you usually somebody you know comes
to you and they want to like you what do
you tell them about Islam with so many
misconceptions out there
yeah with so many misconceptions well
it's it's a it's a tough question but I
think the most important thing is to be
honest in in your pursuit to find God to
find the actual point in existence of
life and whoever is sincere in that
matter whoever sincerely wants to find
and get connected to God he will
certainly do he will certainly do and I
suggest instead of taking chunks out of
the Quran and miss insulating them and
using them out of context I suggest
everybody just to read that book just as
a book as like this I suggest everybody
to read the Quran as a for everybody who
doesn't believe in the Quran as a
potential letter from God okay now
whoever you might okay somebody thinks
maybe there is God but I don't know who
it is
advice Prairie Buddy sincerely read the
Quran
as as it is a potentially a letter from
God to you give beautiful advice
somebody wrote to you a letter a long
long lost loved one yeah you'd make the
time to read it sounded ridges you know
from the Creator as potentially and what
if it is and you just neglected it huh
yeah thank you very much they're like
gorgeous these aqua hiding so long they
come for loads more from vodka sirtuins
soon as day two